but on nfl.com a great piece uh by my
colleague from the nfl media group about
the
the first round grade quarterbacks
available and who wants them and who's
concerned about them
and uh what does it mean for the draft
and free agency that's about to kick
into higher gear
next week tom pelicero of the nfl media
group here on the rich eisen show how
are you tom
uh probably better than i was last march
11th rich i was looking back
uh you know we were talking on tv that
day about how some nfl teams had started
pulling their scouts off the road
if you remember there were certain teams
that put in restrictions for
you know you could only drive to pro
days and you you know some teams flat
out shut it down
and then within 24 to 48 hours tom hanks
had coveted in the nba had stopped
playing pro days were over
and here we are a year later that's
exactly the way it went
no doubt about it but then the new
league year the the league was saying
look
we can do this all virtually and then
they decided let's do the draft
virtually and let's keep everything
uh on point just in case everything does
work out and then the season doesn't
have a single
cancelled game and now here we are back
for another new league year
trying to figure out how it all works
with a a lower cap what are you hearing
about i know that you've been
tweeting about uh so much about this
subject matter
about teams and how they are able were
they they knew it would be less money
coming in
but are the cuts that we're seeing right
now based
on on on the actual hard number being
delivered about 48 hours ago
tom there were certainly teams that were
delaying
some of their business until they had
the final number just because they were
whether you're doing contract extensions
or restructures or you're making
decisions on
cuts you just wanted to have the best
feel possible the most
information um about not just the cap
for 2021
but what direction it may go uh in 2022
and beyond and you know i i talked to
i've talked to a lot of people you know
between
guys who work the salary cap for nfl
teams general managers
agents everybody has different
information
on where the cap is going to go in 2022
2023
but that all affects free agency and
that's going to be
you know part of this extraordinarily
unique dynamic that we have to deal with
is you do have this rash of cuts
uh that is taking place across the
league that rash of cuts
is going to continue uh to next
wednesday and beyond because you know if
you want to use a post
june 1 designation save yourself cap
space now
you have to do that after the league
year begins you're getting it cuts there
you're also going to have teams that
agree to terms with free agents
and then release guys to make room for
them so this is just
the beginning of guys uh hitting the
street and then on top of that you have
uh the fact that i had a long chat with
an agent this morning about this
since we don't have the certainty on the
salary cap in future years but everybody
has a pretty good idea with
the new tv money when those media deals
are done and that should happen sooner
than later
uh the cap should spike in 2023 well if
all the teams are crying poor now and
saying we need to do sub market deals
why am i going to sign a five-year
contract and now getting paid at the
2021 level
when the caps potentially 40 50 million
dollars higher
uh two years down the line you know
there's there's so many moving parts
the marketplace is more unsettled than
it has ever been
uh certainly that i recall in my you
know close to twenty years covering the
nfl the teams are not had not put as
much information out there's very few
as much as we like to say that the uh
the negotiating's allowed to begin on
monday
usually by this time there have been a
lot of clandestine or not
so clandestine meetings at the scouting
combine people have a good idea what
their market is
and i can't tell you how many people
i've spoken to on both sides of this
over the past couple weeks who say we
just don't know where this thing's gonna
land there's not that much information
and and maybe we don't know it because
we're not seeing somebody you know
sitting at steak and shake together at
one in the morning or i'm serious
or or you know uh sharing a glass of
wine
you know uh in the corner of a
steakhouse in indianapolis
they could be doing it by zoom we have
no idea i mean this sort of stuff could
be going down very simply that we just
have no idea about so we don't know the
tracks
and it's always it's a it's a comical
type of a scene too rich normally
because you have agents especially the
ones who represent a lot of players will
be
paying out business cards with the list
of their free agent so that they're
listed the draft guys in the back end
and you got
every 20 minutes people are running
around you're seeing people passing
especially later at night nobody has
time to stop and chat all that now has
been transitioned into
a virtual environment there are teams
that have had zooms with agents
and tried to talk through things that
way but you know as we all know from
living this for the past year
having those conversations in person is
a lot different than trying to do it
with uh
30 minutes virtually here and there so
then let's try and you know instead of
maybe some fans are are have their eyes
spinning in the back of their heads
because we're talking numbers and cap
and business in
such a way that that might not be
translatable which teams do you think or
are hearing
with your ear to the ground as it is are
best positioned for this
uh topsy-turvy uh unconventional
new league year free agency period and
draft which teams are best positioned
do you think well certainly i mean the
colts
just because uh chris balor has been so
frugal with all the cash space that
they've had every year they're going to
be in a strong position
uh the jets between their draft capital
and cap space or another team that's
that's well positioned they've got a lot
of maneuverability they've got to figure
out exactly what their quarterback
situation is
uh the patriots are pretty well
positioned at this point because they
you know between opt-outs and some
releases uh they kind of reset from a
salary cap perspective i would expect
that they're
going to be active and then you have
teams like the browns that always take
care of their cap they're always
um you know well positioned with a lot
of of spending power
you know one of the one of the
fascinating uh dynamics always
is when you have the teams that are
restructuring everybody or cutting
players like the saints
who've been doing this for a decade i
mean they have been
since 2011 um you know when they had
some challenges and the cap penalty and
you know they started doing it's like
they've been a perpetual kicking your
problems into the future type of
situation
there's no magic that's one of the
misconceptions there is no such thing as
cap magic every dollar you spend hits
the cap
eventually all the teams are doing when
they're doing these restructure and they
clear all this cap spaces
now that hits them later it hits them
next year or two years down the line or
uh whenever it may be and so you know
you can you survive like that the saints
have shown
that you can for a long time but you
know in a perfect world they're not
cutting generous chickens and they're
not cutting the manual standards
they're keeping some of these guys
that's that's the price you have to pay
and this is the rare year where even
those teams that don't push their
problems into the future
having to make some of those hard
decisions because the cap lands at
182.5 million which is not only down
about
17 million for 16 million from what it
was a year ago
but is down 25 or 30 million from what
one year ago
every cap manager in the league would
have said that's what the cap will be in
2021 tom pelicero breaking it down my
colleague from the nfl media group and
so um the second overall pick and you
mentioned the jets how they've got a ton
of cap space i mean they
they hold so many cards i mean the
dominoes tumble in a way
um that uh that that that affects so
many
other teams because we're assuming the
jaguars and trevor lawrence because
urban meyer is not taking this swing at
the nfl without the guarantee of
of somebody generationally talented like
him being able to
ha uh be right in front of him and for
his choosing so we're just gonna put
that aside you wrote a piece about all
five of
the first grade first round graded
quarterbacks uh for nfl.com including
lawrence
so the jets have that second overall
pick the texans hold a card too if they
do decide to
put deshaun watson on the table that
might affect the jets thinking because
of their draft capital that they have as
well
what did you glean from all of the
scouts and evaluators about these
quarterbacks that can give us
a little bit of a road map how the next
six seven weeks are going to play out
tom well let's start with trevor
lawrence in my
uh time doing this story and usually i
write it going into the combine there
was no true combine this year so i did
in advance of trey lance's pro day
as we really get into pre-draft season
uh starting tomorrow in all my years i i
can't think of another
quarterback who was as free of questions
going into the draft process as trevor
lawrence
even last year when joe burrow was the
prohibited favorite
you had a lot of scouts who would put
forth fifth round grades on joe burrow
the prior year who were talking about
how you know his arm strength is not at
the top of this class athletic ability
is not the top of this class
one-year producer uh you know all those
types of questions with trevor lawrence
everyone goes yeah you'd like them maybe
to have a few more pounds on him
you know you you wonder a little bit why
he didn't play better against lsu i
didn't play better
against ohio state but he also you know
beat up alabama pretty good as a
as a true freshman in a 15-0 uh season
um he's he's a guy that nobody really
questions and nobody says that they
would have an issue taking him
number one overall the only you know
real debate there is just is he the best
uh suited player to run the offense that
urban meyer has preferred in the past
which is going to be
you'll have some zone read elements not
the trevor lawrence can't do that
because he is you know a tall kid he's a
good athlete he's obviously intelligent
it's really more matter do you want to
expose him uh to getting hit
a little bit more than he necessarily
was at clemson but the consensus is he
goes number one
the consensus based on everyone i've
spoken to so far
is that zach wilson is the second
quarterback and quite likely the number
two overall pick whether that goes to
the jets or someone else with zach
wilson he is a one-year
uh type of a producer obviously had a
fantastic season last year byu
smaller is undersized um he's had an
injury history torn labrum
broken thumb that stuff kind of put him
behind in 2019 cost him some time and
obviously i'm fighting for his job
uh come last august and september but
took advantage of it the big questions
there
are going to be the durability and also
just what kind of a leader
is zach wilson because teams certainly
have heard and some of this
has been written that he's you know
confident borderline cocky
i had one uh high ranking executive
refer to it as
baker mayfield syndrome where he's got
that edge
and he's a guy who you like it up to a
point but then when things go
sideways if you're not playing well you
know can you toe
uh that same kind of a line so there's
definitely an evaluation going on there
but
you know the tape is impressive i mean
he comes across as a gunslinger
teams like that uh the you know the way
that he can fit some throws in
um and so certainly he seems to be on
solid ground where things really get
interesting
is going to be the third fourth fifth
quarterbacks
take it because matt jones has picked up
steam from alabama
he helped himself on and off the field
really uh
at the senior bowl the only one of those
top five quarterbacks who got to go to
an all-star game this year
which also means because of the covid
restrictions he's the only guy
who's had face-to-face in-person time
with any nfl team
so far in the pre-draft process some of
the others might get it at pro days but
even that
is up to the school nfl teams are not
allowed to set up dinner
visits nothing they're not even allowed
to set up time to speak with the player
at the pro day unless the school
specifically
puts it on the schedule so mac jones got
a little bit ahead
uh he's somebody who teams wanted to dig
into
from a personality perspective because
some of the word out of the school
early on particularly when he was you
know backing up to a tonga by lola and
jalen hurts was just that
you know he was a hot head he's a former
tennis player who was pretty good
uh as a kid uh he would have you know he
was kind of the john mcenroe it sounds
like of the youth tennis circuit where
he had some
some fits and um you know there was a
question about mental toughness but he
answered a lot of that he's really
highly regarded
uh in terms of his football iq his
preparation uh is really good he's just
not
the best athlete in the class he doesn't
have the best arm in the class
so the question with him is just you
know can he how much better can he get
you know the floor is high but where's
the ceiling can he be a top starter or
does he top out as a borderline
starter you know top backup type of a
guy you haven't said just
you hold on just to give you a little
bit of a break so you could swallow or
get a glass of water this is amazing tom
pelosi
i know it's your show no no no no no no
no you gave me a broad-based question no
it's not it is not it's also my way to
reset for the radio audience in case
they're just tuning into this fantastic
breakdown
you haven't mentioned justin field's
name yet you're
so so that leaves trey lance and justin
fields of people you haven't mentioned
yet
so what what's your evaluation again
trevor lawrence one
zack wilson two seems to be the way that
most people have it stacked
right now right then three four fives
where it's interesting we just talked
about mack jones
trey lance is kind of the amazing
question mark quite frankly because
he started 17 games at north dakota
state
only one of those games came in the past
14 months because their season got moved
uh to the spring and he's only thrown 30
passes in any of those games
twice so he operates a pro style offense
which everybody likes
but on the flip side you also are
running a ton of play action
you got wide receivers running wide open
you're playing in the missouri valley
football conference
and he had no all-star game so
everything seems to be good from uh
intelligence standpoint
people have liked talking to him when
they've gotten him uh virtually
he seems to throw it well enough they
want to see you know some accuracy
questions just because again he had guys
running wide open all over the place
i spoke to his quarterbacks coach quincy
avery yesterday who told me
he's gonna be a little bit more compact
in his delivery they've been working on
that since october
because of course he didn't play
football after october so he's had
nothing
uh the time to work on that so they're
hoping just to tighten up
uh his stroke a little bit uh but it's
also just you know can you bet on them
that's what one um you know executive
that i really trust with a strong
college scouting background told me was
just
you know you got 17 games and there's
nothing on the tape that's going to give
you the answers
your your question is going to be do you
believe in the kid
do you believe he can do the things you
haven't seen because there's not going
to be any more tape you can feel like
he's going to make a big jump
you just don't have that additional tape
so you got to take a guess now i would
say
and you brought up justin fields from
ohio state and i'm not
putting him fifth i'm not ranking them
me in any way
at this point and this is not my opinion
i don't watch tape i just talked to the
people who do this yes sir for a living
i can tell you there are some scouts
i've talked to who
like what they see on tape from trey
lance better than justin fields
there are people who think trey lance
even as a runner is better than justin
fields
now we've also seen fields be tough
be productive do it on the biggest stage
of the questions with him arise uh from
two areas
one is what type of leader is he going
to be
because he is a quieter type of
personality everybody has been around
people who like him say yeah he's a
little bit more quiet
a little more to himself uh his first
year there was some
criticism just about did he really try
to get to know his teammates because he
was coming and trying to win the job
something he came out of his shell more
last year um
you know he was embraced there now
teammates uh vouch for him
but that just anytime you've got a
quieter player whether that's uh
kyler murray was kind of like that
justin herbert last year was kind of
like that
you know they're not the typical alpha
male and so that it was something you
dig into and then the other piece of it
is just how ready is he
for the nfl game because the ohio state
offense is kind of notorious for
limiting
what the quarterback has to read and
that goes back a number of years now
a scout text me last night after reading
the story and said well
you know ryan day does have a lot of pro
style routes that you see
uh him throw but it's the difference
between reading the whole field and
going through the progressions
versus the way that the ohio state
coaches kind of teach them
uh to read plays out and i spoke to his
quarterback coach
john beck who said yeah i understand
where scouts wants that tape
and they are they have questions because
i did too they said they talked through
plays about just
why is the ball going here why on this
you know you don't have the deep shot
and then you just you don't throw the
five yard under route you take off
running
and the answer quebec was this is not in
being inefficient
this is what he's being coached to do in
other words
again you're in an issue where it's not
a matter of aptitude
everybody says that he's smart it's a
matter of you haven't seen him
do it and so is that going to translate
better than maybe some other
quarterbacks who try to make that
transition in the past
a lot of stuff and the great thing about
it tom pelicero and just to
just to give you more kudos for your
piece you really even
didn't even scratch the surface of all
the details that's in there on nfl.com i
appreciate the call
look for my call over the next couple
weeks let's keep revisiting this issue
because as you know the deck keeps
getting shuffled
certainly based on what we're going to
see next week with the new league gear
thanks for the call tom
thanks for having me richard you bet
that's tom pelosa follow him on twitter
i do
great information just great stuff right
there hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here